michel rocard à la réunion pour quatre
jours le premier ministre qui
accueillera lundi sur place le pape jean
paul ii que l'on vient de voir à
l'instant il ya le premier ministre donc
a été confronté aujourd'hui à la
situation sociale et économique que du
plus peuplé et du plus pauvre aussi des
départements d'outre-mer récemment
dévasté par un cyclone 35 % de taux de
chômage parmi la population active et
50000 personnes concernées par leur rmi
c'est à dire le revenu minimum
d'insertion voyez tout de suite de nos
envoyés spéciaux à saint denis
le reportage donc de daniel fortier
l'eau et alain thomas
tout y était la foule le soleil et même
les mariés le voyage officiel du premier
ministre à la réunion a démarré à la
mairie de saint denis sur les landes une
victoire celle de gilbert annette maire
socialiste de saint denis depuis un mois
à peine
michel rocard avait donc une double
raison de venir saluer le nouveau maire
d'une capital détenus par la droite
depuis 20 ans c'est la deuxième visite
en deux ans de michel rocard à la
réunion mais cette fois il y vient en
tant que premier ministre ce qui lui
permet de ne pas arriver les mains vides
contrat de ville avec saint denis
contracte plan état région
autrement dit engagements financiers
précise et chiffrée de part et d'autre
et surtout mise en place du rmi
cinquante mille personnes vont en
bénéficier ce qui place la réunion au
rang de premier département français
pour le nombre de bénéficiaires par
habitant il y à issy soixante mille
chômeurs déclarés à la libye
après le passage du premier ministre
devant le conseil régional et le conseil
général
deux institutions politiques présidée
par l'opposition michel rocard se rendra
demain dans la commune de tampon au sud
de l'île
c'est la zone la plus touchée par le
cyclone firinga le 29 janvier
michel rocard veut apprécier sur place
l'étendue des dégâts
la deuxième journée de visite à la
réunion du premier ministre promet donc
d'être moins institutionnel que la
première et ce ne sont pas les
réunionnais qu'ils ont attendu des
heures parfois il s'en plaindront